تمضي ايران في حمله القمع ضد المحتاجين
بكل الوسائل فعلى صعيد المحاكمات اصدر
القضاء الايراني اول حكم بالاعدام على
متظاهر على خلفيه الاحتجاجات وياتي الحكم
بعد ساعات من توجيه القضاء الايرانيه
لاتهامه لنحو 800 متظاهر جديد في 30
محافظات وبحسب ارقام القضاء الايراني تم
توجيهه الاتهام الى اكثر من 2200 شخص
نصفهم في طهران منذ بدء الاحتجاجات وافاد
موقع ميزان التابع للقضاء الايرانيه بان
164 ظاهره سيحاكمون اعتبارا من الخميس
المقبل بتهم اثاره الشغب اضافه موقع ميزان
ان محتجين سيحاكمون بيتهم التامر ضد
الدوله والتحريض على القتل بالاضافه الى
تهم الدعايه ضد النظام واستهدفه والامن
اشاره موقع وميزان التابع للقضاء الايراني
الى ان التهم على المواجهه للمحتاجين قد
تصل عقوبتها الى الاعدادات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]